voters eyes don't lie that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right as usual Democrat leadership
misreads why the public and even their
own constituents at this point are down
on Biden
the Republicans are one-trick Pony
talking about the president's age that's
all they talk about we have to go out
and talk about the accomplishments just
as much as they talk about lies and
misdirection and red herrings we think
that that's going to prove to be a
winning formula once again for all
Democrats and for President Biden and
president vice president Harris a win a
winning formula is that I said oh we'll
see you see I have this crazy idea that
Americans don't want to go into debt to
buy stuff like gas groceries or make car
payments in Newsweek writer Lee Habib
noted that the combination of runaway
costs and high interest rates has been
catastrophic for ordinary Americans as
the average car payment surged to nearly
730 dollars a month with the length of
those loans extended to a record-setting
68 months
as for gasoline while Biden's insane
squeeze on pipelines and exploration is
killing the family budget in July 2020
gas was a mere 227 a gallon in July of
2023 the average was 371 a whopping 63
percent increase and it's even gone up
since then
so all Americans feel the pain of
Biden's radical green agenda because
everything that travels by car by plane
or truck is now more expensive and it's
all on the Democrats
the economy as I've been saying for two
years Remains the top priority for
voters across the country and Biden's
numbers remain really Grim 58 in that
new CNN poll are saying his policies are
making the economy worse
and the only thing the White House says
in response is
now with bidenomics in action and some
of our investments playing out 35 000
Investments and 4 500 communities across
this country we are starting to see some
results
well at least they try to spin the
economy issue they don't really even try
to explain how their border policy is
really helping America we know it's not
this week we thought we saw the
beginning of a dam break with comments
made by mayor Eric Adams in New York
every service in this city is going to
be impacted all of us are going to be
impacted by this
I said it last year when we had fifteen
thousand and I'm telling you now with
110 000. the city we knew
we're about to lose
but instead of calling out the White
House Adams blamed Republican Governor
Greg Abbott
we turned this city around in 20 months
and then what happened
started with a Madman down in Texas
decided he wanted to bust people up to
New York City
Adams isn't a serious man neither is
Massachusetts liberal Governor Maura
Healy calling in the National Guard to
help with the influx of illegals there
when she should have been calling Biden
and telling him it's time to end the
madness at the border
but regardless we know mallorcas is a
DHS secretary knows that this issue is
hurting them politically because they're
now mulling the Absurd move of trying to
force the illegals to stay in Texas
until their Asylum hearings take place
by the way the current case backlog for
immigration cases is four years
now think about the irony here Biden
ditched Trump's highly effective remain
in Mexico policy and instead now wants
to adopt a remain in Texas policy that's
cute
now wonder as numbers on immigration On
the Border in the toilet and it's not
just New York in Chicago they're now
building massive winterized tent camps
there before the cold weather sets in
what could go wrong there well here's
one thing
tensions have risen between migrants and
police Tuesday CPD says a 20-year-old
man was taken into custody after
threatening an officer he's charged with
two misdemeanors
and Chicago residents are increasingly
Fed Up
I don't want them there take them
someplace else or send them back to
Venezuela I don't care where they go
this is wrong you get 73 of the people
whom this in this city are black people
whatever done for them
it's stunning though how dismissive
Democrats can be when they're pressed
ever so lightly on the problems that
their policies caused or made worse late
today on MSNBC Nancy Pelosi was asked
about what she thinks could be done to
address the crime in drug epidemic in
her own hometown
it's about mental health issues that
lead to homeless it's about drug use
that lead to homeless about affordable
housing but we're very proud of our city
our city is alive and vibrant and
thriving and it's great
uh I don't even know what that means
well it's Devastation as far as the eye
can see in Blue State America
idiotic policies have led to nightmarish
results we've reported on them and there
is some recognition among some Democrats
that they do need to reverse course
after seeing its City sink into
Zombieland despair Portland city leaders
finally voted to ban the use of hard
drugs on public property
now who could have thought that making
it legal to use math smoke Fentanyl and
heroin on public property was a bad idea
politicians are reading the polls here
drug legalization marijuana in
particular and decriminalization
generally has across the board been a
complete disaster everywhere it's been
adopted I predict other states will see
the Folly of their ways
now this issue is another black guy for
liberals and it's an obvious fact that
drug use is bad for business it fuels
crime psychosis and even death
David friedrichs of Portland fire and
rescue station one says his station
alone responded to a total of 76
overdose calls over the Labor Day
weekend in some cases we treat the same
patient several times in the same week
and we know through our partners at AMR
that the same patient has overdosed
multiple times in a day and knowing that
when that even when we try to help our
help is unwanted where's on all of us
at this point it's worth asking how much
more wreckage do we need to see with our
own eyes before the Democrat power base
really admits it has more than a
messaging problem on its hands
angle viewers know my connection and
interest in Minneapolis especially with
what's happened with crime and drugs
since the Floyd riots
the police Staffing shortage there is
unsustainable according to their police
chief and there's been a sharp increase
in criminal gang activity assaults and
carjackings last week a far left
official with Minnesota's Liberal dfl
Party was violently attacked outside her
home and posted this
four very young men all carrying guns
beat me violently down to the ground in
front of our kids the young men held our
neighbors up at gunpoint when they ran
over and tried to help me all in broad
daylight I have no doubt they've done
this before we need to catch these young
people and hold them in custody and
prosecute them
well we're glad she's okay
but she could have helped prevent more
crime if she also recanted what she was
calling for in June 2020
dismantling the Minneapolis Police
Department
clearly Democrats need to do a lot of
soul-searching about the wreckage
they've left in their wake and if they
don't change direction soon I am telling
you tonight voters will be searching
else Elsewhere for candidates with real
solutions not silly Spin and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else